and thanks to num focus
for sponsoring these uh just by quick
way of intro well today we're going to
talk about desk this is going to be a an
introduction to
desk let me go ahead and
start let me make these slides a little
bigger
i want to focus on exploratory data
analysis and machine learning
the reason why i talk about desk i work
at a desk company i work at coiled which
was founded by the creator of desk matt
rocklin and i previously worked with him
and some others at anaconda which is
known for the anaconda distribution of
python and the conda package manager
which shared an office with num focus
which was really cool
um
so today i hope you if you're here for
desk you're in the right spot if you're
here for parallel python
you're in the right spot if you're here
for
data frames that you want to make you
want to go bigger on or like i like i'd
like to read in more data in this data
frame do stuff like that you're in the
right spot
and if you're here for psychic learn
estimators you'd like to scale you're
also in the right spot
um
there are three things i think we can
accomplish hopefully over the next hour
or so i want to build kind of
fundamentally to introduce you best to
desk into parallel and distributed
python in general we need to build a
little bit of intuition and i i hope i
have some kind of germain code samples
that will
ram this home
um i also
from feedback from previous talks
instead of just showing bashing you over
the head with desk examples i want to
show you some use cases
uh one of my you know being privileged
to work at a company that sells desk we
get to talk to lots of people who use
desk in industry people generally
speaking at least back in the day
attended meetups you know network look
for jobs hire stuff like that um so the
business focus if you're in financial
services life science
and and energy although i'll change i
would broaden that just geospatial in
general which includes a lot of climate
science
mining tons of fun things there we see
lots of desk usage so if you're
interested in those industries or if
you're in those industries there's an
overlap with desk um and then we'll i'll
try to demonstrate some of these so that
you can see
what i hope is like fundamental
distributed python concept i'm going to
apply that i'm going to show you a desk
example and hopefully you'll say oh gosh
that's like pretty easy i don't have to
worry about all that hard stuff
and then i'm going to map that over to a
few examples for some for some industry
specific stuff and in particular i'll be
really explicit about a finance example
um
because it uses open data it's kind of
the easiest to share
so that's those are objectives hopefully
at the end of this you kind of leave
with this sense
um just as a quick disclaimer uh because
we're recording the things i kind of
have to do this i i'm going to share
these representative workloads i'm not
sharing private information from anyone
i speak to or have an nda with or you
know i speak to in a business context if
i use a company name which i will try to
this is all from the community um so
we'll talk for example capital one is a
big user of gas they blog about it they
extend das they do lots of cool stuff i
will share an example from them when
relevant um but that's not implying a
commercial relationship of any kind or
any private uh data that i would be
sharing
okay boring disclaimer over uh big
picture
most
oh and and just sorry i'm gonna i have a
tendency to just plow through so i will
be checking the chat for questions and
stuff if you want to fire them out as we
go um i i have a few spots where i'll
try to come up for air but if you don't
stop me i'm just going to keep i'm going
to keep wrong
so let's start with a little bit of
introduction around kind of the need for
this why someone might want to scale
python what the heck we're doing here so
um a couple of things that are obvious
but worth pointing out
most kind of quantitative fields have
two things two trends going on they have
many but these two are pretty solid data
volumes going out the wazoo and lots of
python adoption
and so
if uh if you are using python which
you're more likely to not to do or
you're hiring people who'll be using
python because they now teach this as
you know cs101 and you're trying to deal
with these large data volumes you're
going to run some challenges and you
might want some tools to help you solve
that das is one of those tools it helps
scale python to large data sets
and if you learn desk you can apply it
to the existing python code you have
you don't have to reinvent the wheel so
we're going to come in today and i'm
going to show you kind of two approaches
the desk approach to your standard pi
data stack to the dashed version of an
array the dash version of a data frame
but this is critical you can also just
dasify your code and take whatever
you're writing in python
and just go ahead and parallelize it now
there are some things that can get
tricky but you're this is what desk
enables you to do build arbitrary task
graphs which is really powerful and
really fun
um okay next all right
so to put some data behind this the data
growth has exploded you don't need me to
tell you this
here's a chart that shows the explosion
and data just for full disclosure i made
this chart up this isn't real but the
actual i mean the date this chart is
wrong but the date the trend is
absolutely true and i found a fun
example uh from the wall street the wall
street journal of all places a couple of
weeks ago
they published these
these graphics to show data growth over
time in areas that i wouldn't have
expected
so for example on the left here this is
major league baseball stacked cast data
and they were using they showed a number
of these and i cherry picked two
and they used a grain of rice to try to
show that i think a grain of rice was
equal in data size to about to a single
image to a photograph so snap a photo
with your
uh with your kit with your camera phone
and then that would be one grain of rice
and so
the major league baseball for the
purposes of
teams analytics and then stuff i'm sure
they sell to fans and others they
generate about five terabytes of
statcast data per game 162 games in a
season plus add-in playoffs plus however
many teams they're generating a
significant amount of data whereas
previously if you think about baseball
historically which i think is worth
doing you know how did you track data in
baseball well they've always done that
you kept score you know i remember used
to keep squall used to keep score by
with the pen and paper and you draw you
know
anyway like it's kind of wild that all
of a sudden it went from this very
manual process that people had done for
us
really long time
to now all this additional data that's
in that's the non-structured stuff this
is the images this is the video the
players moving around looking at
mechanics all sorts of things that
previously didn't exist um and then on
the right over here is kind of the
example that you'd expect which is what
youtube which has exploded uh and i
won't even cite the growth here because
it's just kind of it's it boggles the
mind and it's probably not your
enterprise or corporate situation your
personal situation but they're now up to
something like five petabytes per day
which is kind of wild 122 tons of rice
so each baseball game is 235 pounds
every day of youtube is 122 tons that's
pretty nuts
um
and because i work for a vendor i also
kind of want to critique vendors for a
second um and there's a another fun
article from the new york times uh that
and i also aim this for the pi data
audience sometimes there are people in
attendance maybe not tonight but
sometimes there are people in terms of
highly data events who are new to python
and new to programming in general and i
was an english major at school i'm not
even necessarily i'm not necessarily i'm
probably a bad programmer by any stretch
a bad coder uh python's one of those
things that's very accessible i i think
that's why i like it i hope that's why
maybe others like it um but there's
still people who are on the fence and
and i'm surprised how many people i talk
to these days who were like i'm still
thinking about it and nothing wrong with
that good dude be open but please dive
in um and when i ask folks like why
haven't you gotten into this yet like
what are you waiting for one of the
things they tend to say is like well i
work at a big company and i think
someone i can use a tool that's going to
do what i need to do and so i found this
article to really flesh this point out
and the author writes
by the time you become truly proficient
at programming chances are that whatever
you set out to write would be available
in some form from a software publisher
it's really interesting it's january's
new york times
um but of course i'm being a little
devious here
it was in january's new york times but i
got the year wrong it wasn't this year
it was written in 1984. and i think the
subsequent code quote is actually really
illustrative for us and i'm assuming
here in the audience that if you haven't
learned python yet you're still working
in this data space right data volumes
are going like crazy um the people that
you may that you may lead or manage are
going to be learning this
computers will become as common to this
generations 90s as television was to
their parents
but the vast majority of parents do not
repair television sets right for
television i love this
work in the broadcasting industry in any
capacity so if you take those three i
was like don't learn uh to write code
back in the 80s because just like you
might watch tv you don't repair the tv
set or write for you're not in the show
bit you're not in show business you
don't work in broadcasting
of course i would i posit that that is
absolutely not true for us that almost
all of us
especially given this just
especially or
due to this large data growth are are
absolutely working in the data industry
or at least are adjacent to this it's
quite common everybody has this problem
we're all working in it
ergo it's worth to learn now i may be
preaching to the choir here this is a
fine day data meetup everyone may be
very proficient but uh if you know
someone who's still on the fence like
maybe play a joke on them with something
like this
um okay so preamble over well let's get
into some code here let's get let's
start let's first talk desk architecture
and why you might use it um more
specifically technical and then we'll
show some examples
um
so first up why use dask uh there this
is the first question i oh i want to
scale python or i want big data frames
there's lots of options for this and
we'll go through some of these um but
principally spark is probably the one
that most people are familiar with
they'll say well if i have python and i
want to work with lots of data i would
use spark that's the standard pi spark
gives me a python api there are tools
within the ecosystem like koalas that
would give me data frames and they're
familiar interfaces what's the deal why
would i want to bother with anything
else well
high level reasons
desk number one has a familiar api i'll
direct your attention over here on to
the right note these three lines of code
import pandas read csv
group by when i do this in desk it's
import pandas
import das data frame excuse me read csv
and group by now there are there is a
slight difference that the astute reader
will note this dot compute will get
there
but it is very very similar the api is
very similar
second you can use das on your laptop or
on a cluster
this reason is near and dear to me which
is why i titled this talk to the cluster
and back we're gonna we're gonna show
this today
this one i think is really really
important especially for people who work
in corporate environments where things
get really locked down and you might
find yourself in the in the case of
someone trying to use spark kind of
forced onto what might be referred to as
an edge node or a gateway node or
something where i have to be in this
area with these binaries and all this
configuration already set it up so that
i can then just do something like
probably not read a csv but read a
parquet file or something like that and
do some processing
um
so that's reason two familiar api scale
laptop cluster and back
reason three dash integrates with the pi
data ecosystem this is because das is
pure python it's a python data package
so not just pandas and numpy and
scikit-learn but also the rest of what's
in what's in python and pi data we can
if you use dash you can scale arbitrary
python code which is really really
powerful you know python gets this this
bad rap fair unfair for being slow and
not scaling well but something like gas
we can maybe still be slow but will be
faster or if we're distributed
which makes something that's easy to use
now scalable
um
and that feeds into bolt number four
which is dash supports complex
applications so you've noticed this
maybe you're annoyed by this kind of gif
over here on the right this is a more
complicated task graph i'll step through
an example like this at a bit of a high
level but you can build really complex
tasks or really complex
parallel parallel code struggling for
the word of your jobs with desk you can
do it really easily in fact this will
actually be our first example of code
and then the final thing in one of the
favorite features for people who are
desk users is the the real-time
diagnostics the desk dashboard which
gives us a lot of rich information about
what desk is doing
it's not perfect by any stretch but it's
a it's a heck of a lot nicer than
looking at a bunch of java stack traces
or maybe being in in uh grafana or some
things you're trying to parse out what's
going on with your spark code
and not to keep throwing shaded spark
but there'll be a few more jabs
throughout the throughout the evening
um and just to ram this point home about
a laptop to cluster in the back uh
the this i think is a critical thing
when i think about a standard developer
workflow now if you're if you're kind of
saddled or burdened or you're forced to
work with these large data sets you're
almost always going to do some sort of
sampling to work locally right you're
going to develop on your laptop or your
maybe maybe instead of laptop this is in
fact a big server or something like that
but you're going to have you're going to
have some sort of environment we can
quickly hack on stuff so if you want to
use desk here it's great it's pip
install desk and distributed and then
import them and run
same thing on a big server so what i'll
show here in a bit is dash scaling
really nicely vertically so that by that
i mean if this laptop has four cores and
16 gigs of ram and pandas uses just a
single core which is what it does when i
use a dash data frame i'll get to four
cores
i move over to a big server and aws
azure gcp they'll give me huge servers i
can get one with 100 cores or 96 cores i
can scale all the way up to those i
don't have to worry about networking and
all the sorts of things that come when i
go to a cluster so i can get all i can
squeeze a lot of juice out of one of
these big servers and most importantly
it's the exact same code import task
import distributed go forth
and then what i posit to you is that
when you go to a cluster now there's
going to be some more mechanics here and
i'll show some examples at the very end
of the talk this infrastructure won't be
our focus
but when we go to a cluster we're going
to do the exact same thing import task
import distributed we'll have a cluster
object we're going to need to have
created some way somehow but once we
pass that in all of our code remains the
same this is way way different in my
opinion
but this is way way different from how
you might work with spark or other tools
especially for getting spark things like
uh you know if you used to write mpi if
you're working in hpc systems
your code is going to be very different
this is not the case you know i'm hand
waving a little bit to be clear but i i
consider this to be one of the strongest
value propositions of desk
prototype develop deploy you know small
medium large you're you're essentially
passing the same code
um
now to be fair i think when i described
so that's why we used ask let's talk
about why not to use it and so
these come by the way directly from the
das docs these are the best practices
when not to use das let's be explicit
first up if you have the opportunity to
use better algorithms or data structures
simply moving from something like csv to
parquet or if you can if you can chunk
your data you may find that you're able
to get the performance you need i will
see some i'll show examples of bad
algorithms i don't know if i have
examples of good ones but obviously but
as you grow in competence and your
understanding of the problem your
ability to build python or your language
you you can improve performance without
using the task um uh better file formats
i kind of i already shared that part a
big one for most for a lot of users is
going to something like parquet from csb
which is more efficient
um step three compile so another num
focus sponsored project that is near and
dear to people who are at anaconda is
number
as an example so
python if you would like to compile your
code so that this way
depending on how this is done of course
it can vary but a compilation step would
make python run a lot faster and there
are tools that do this uh one in
particular that i like is called number
it has a just-in-time compiler jit
compiler and this will this will
drastically increase the speed of your
code now there is a compilation step
you're not running it interpreted but it
works very nicely um the fourth one this
one's kind of obvious but important
sample just create a representative
sample of your data that way you don't
need to distribute because you don't
have big data you have data that fits in
memory or fits comfortably in memory of
pandas and the fifth one is profile uh
ian onsvald who wrote this book called
high performance python uh and speaks at
a lot of pi data and python events is a
master of this and it's something i
understand very poorly but i have a copy
of his book and i'd recommend watching
one of his talks because he does a great
job oops excuse me i'm showing you kind
of how to squeeze all the juice out of
your code and how to profile of course
desk has a profile or two so which
you'll get to see
all right excellent um
i in the interest of time here i've
taken too much on this intro let's let's
get into some code and uh jump over
oops i didn't mean to i didn't need to
stop sharing i'm sorry uh
let me oh gosh what did i do
sorry i'll share back again we'll share
everything
okay this is gcp
but i want to share
my slides
all right
there we go
uh just as a quick check i hope if
anyone's still there i don't know
i'm showing a jupiter notebook right now
and it
should be kind of zoomed in how most
start with desk can anybody see that
or am i on like my slack or personal
email embarrassing myself we can see
that
perfect okay great so let's uh let's
jump in here and let's
get rid of both marks
so
um we're going to start with some dash
examples so here's how most people come
to desk with either they're either
coming from a numpy array or a das data
frame as data frames are more popular
i'm going to start with um with an array
just to show an example so
we'll create a the das version of this
and we will quickly visualize what our
array looks like so i just created this
empty array here
and i've got this single array a single
task this is exactly what you have with
numpy and in fact all desk does with
desk arrays or you know all it does but
it's core a desk array is a collection
of vampire arrays a dash data frame is a
collection of pando's data frames um we
want to parallelize things and das will
do a lot of smart stuff to help us
figure this out but we can manually
split this up here into chunks so that
we can start to get some parallelism so
same thing and by the way this is meant
to be a quick right we're gonna we're
gonna go fast you're just trying to
build intuition it's not like all this
code and anything i show is gonna be in
docs and examples on the desk site i'll
show you where all that is
um but here we go so now we've got three
we've got this array we've chunked it
into three chunks of five
and we can start to run operations in
parallel so i just ran here very quickly
a sum operation
and uh while it wouldn't this because
this data is small you wouldn't
necessarily have noticed
but
das built a task graph here that shows
these three independent sum operations
that it will run so instead of running
okay take the array and sum the array as
one task it did it as three tasks we're
starting to get some parallelism
um now what's really interesting here
and actually let's just make sure i
should be able to check here if i run y
when i look at my result here what's
interesting is all i see is this
representation desk is actually lazily
computed so i need to compute this to
get the result this is when my code
actually executes otherwise desk is just
building a task graph so this this is a
very powerful concept and i'm probably
doing a poor job here of explaining it
but basically what i'm hoping to show is
that when we
ran an operation like sum this array i
would have expected an answer back you
know give me give me the answer instead
i get back
either a visualization this is the
actual task graph and and and what this
looks like this is this is the shape of
the arrays these are the chunks these
are the data types and then i need to
explicitly call compute to tell task
okay execute this and return the result
to my local machine or in this excuse me
return the result to my client which in
this case just happens to be my local
machine
um not to scare anyone but one of the
like a fun way to kind of blow up your
local machine i mean not that it would
be irrecoverable but it's to call
compute when the data that you're
returning is not say like a single like
a float but a monstrous array or a huge
data frame you will then dashboard and
try to serialize this and bring it back
to you from the cluster
um but anyway so that's our first little
quick intro let's do something a little
bit more fun so let's build a more
complex array so now we've got a series
of three of those same arrays
and we're still summing them
along the along the zeroth axis and so
now we can see a more complex task graph
now again this the code didn't become
appreciably more complex i'm still just
running this one operation
let's go ahead and i'm gonna keep
running the visual visualizing these
next few steps let's add what we just
created this array let's add it to add
it to its transpose
so
in this case das took this operation x x
plus its transpose
and we got this slightly more complex
graph we didn't have to build this
ourselves this is what das is doing for
us automatically this is this is the
kind of core dash algorithm that work
and i'm going to have a little bit more
fun here so let's make this more
complicated let's add in a matrix
multiply and we're going to make this
graph
even more complicated now again
or not again but you could build all of
this manually you don't necessarily need
to use dash to do it there are other
options but even within desk you could
manually build a task graph in das it's
represented as a key value as a series
of keys and values as addict you could
write this out if you wanted to but kind
of the nice the wonder the majesty here
of desk it does it for you all right and
we're going to keep going here final one
is let's add in a matrix multiply and a
mean and we'll visualize all of this
and here's what our task graph looks
like now
so
hopefully what the idea here being
there's a lot of complexity uh when it
comes to running stuff in parallel
das will do a lot of this work for you
so that you can write code that looks
like
standard python pi data code that's the
core idea of what's going on here and
i'll jump over to documentation here for
a second
but the desk docs run through all of
this stuff and you can see this at
docs.dash.org and you can you can look
at the structure but also a ton of fun
examples on how to set all this up for
numpy style arrays task arrays as well
as for data frames and these uh i won't
jump to spend too much time on data
frames
but you're going to see something that
looks very similar just like the uh the
numpy example
and i will check quickly okay great
we're still rolling so
uh with this kind of quick okay high
level interface in mind let's go to the
other direction and let's say
it's like gus you told me hey das can
paralyze das gives me big data frames
big arrays big scikit-learn style
estimators wonderful but it can also
paralyze arbitrary python code let's do
that now
so
right here i have three functions
increment double and add and i've got a
small set of data
and we have a little for loop here we're
going to go through
serial operation increment double and
add i'll just go ahead and run that
right now now this will run quickly we
could slow it down by adding in like
importing time.sleep and putting it in
here but i won't do that for the moment
i just want to show you what this would
look like when we
we paralyzed this with desk so same code
same exact for loop let's run this with
desk and the way we'll do this is we're
going to build a task graph
and we're going to use an interface
called desk delayed
desk has two principal
lower level collections delayed and
futures and delayed we'll build a task
graph that we can then specify when we'd
like to execute and i can i can append
or i can add to my code that's existing
for loop inc
double and add by just wrapping it with
dash dot delay
there's also a decorator here which is
another way you'll see this that'll just
be really explicit dash dot delay
and so now we can run this and we can
visualize what das is doing
and so what das did here was it it
looked at our code it looked at those
three functions and said okay here's a
for loop which of these can i run in
parallel and which are dependent on the
others and figured this out and like
maybe this isn't that complicated but i
think this is pretty cool and maybe
that's just more about me i don't know
but take a look at this we're going to
look at these functions in a little bit
of depth here so the first one increment
takes as an argument x which is what
we're looping through and then the
second one double takes as in as an
argument x as well and this is no
different from the code here they're
just the function and the function's
argument
are arguments delayed which may sound a
little tricky but it delayed takes in
two arguments the function
double and then what it that function
took as an argument so
das looked at these and said oh gosh i
can execute these in parallel because
they're not dependent upon each other
but add it needs the result of a and b
to be to be computed before or to be to
be computed before it can it can repeat
itself so thus it constructs this graph
and figures it out which is pretty handy
and we'll show in our kind of subsequent
examples is where this cut we can take
this kind of uh this behavior we can
apply more complex stuff than
increment double and add and we can get
some pretty good scaling behavior
without having to really understand a
ton about what we would want to
distribute and why
all right um oh and the documentation
for delayed and futures is also here in
the das docs and you can see oh gosh
i blatantly stole this example right
from the first you know right from the
front page uh but it's in here you can
take a look at these ink double and add
all right so let's jump back quickly uh
to slides and i want to spend a second
on the finance use case i hope this is
okay
um
if anyone has maybe i could
i could pause for a second how am i
doing we're about halfway we're about
halfway through on time um i've got a
number of use cases to show these will
be one code heavy example for finance
the others will be higher level if
you're if you're already bored hopefully
that would be more fun and then i'll
talk a little bit about different ways
you can deploy desk on clusters like
kubernetes and all these fun open source
options
um
okay no one's complaining we'll go forth
all right uh
let me go back into slideshow mode
so uh in financial services it's a huge
umbrella term of course uh there's lots
there's lots of pandas and spreadsheets
and therefore ergo there is lots of desk
we see desk used a lot in bag testing
and simulation risk modeling
and you know what's the hole in these
end-to-end ml workflows that have
everyone so hot and bothered um but you
won't hear any preening from me about
that or at least not much
the data formats we tend to see no
surprise numpy and pandas this is a
spreadsheet time series driven world
and one thing i think is interesting to
note are the professions uh you kind of
heard my anti-data science bias you'll
often see people here who are quants or
researchers and of course engineers
versus maybe your your uh
your data scientists of today
and then interestingly just as an
infrastructure note we see lots of
on-premises uh computing which makes
sense um some cloud and then some hpc
which can be both uh on-prem and uh in
the cloud
all right um
we the reason and
most of these workflows that we've seen
especially in financial services but
this is broader across other industries
are embarrassingly parallel tasks and
this graphic here on the right is the
one that we saw previously so instead of
ink and double it could be things like
okay we're just going to read data in
parallel from a giant object store or
file storage and then we're going to run
some simulations on it we're going to do
like a monte carlo simulation or
something like that where we can run a
bunch of these in parallel and we're
simply confused
um
then there are also more complex tasks
and actually i think in the order of my
slides i'm going to show you
uh let me show you one of these examples
before we
go further into this
so let's jump up here
i'm going to import task
and
critically here i'm also going to import
from dash distributed uh the client and
i'm going to create
a local cluster here
and this local cluster concept is is
pretty important um
and i say pretty important that that
sounds that's very weak let me pull this
over here to the right
so we can see it as we run
hopefully this isn't too smushed this
may be a little smushed i apologize
let's go back to simple interface view
okay
great so desk desk has two methods of
running uh you can run with import as we
saw the first time uh desk array the
local scheduler um i imported desk array
and i just used it there was nothing
else you could do the same thing with
das data frame go forth uh and
parallelize
there's another option which is the
distributed scheduler
and someone confusingly we're going to
run the distributed scheduler here on my
local machine it's some local host
but what this does it does number a
couple of things most importantly it
gives me access to this desk dashboard
so it shows me for example that uh maybe
very dangerously i'm letting desk use
all of my
logical cores and all of my memory even
though i'm also running zoom in chrome
which is little which is a lot
and i can look here and see okay the
scheduler is running here and here each
of my workers
now the nice thing about this or why
this is really important one is to
profile the two this is how you also
then is this is one of the key steps to
then pushing out to a cluster
in the future what we'll do is we'll
pass in a cluster object explicitly to
this client at the moment uh without
specifying an argument dasc will create
a local cluster and say okay we're using
a local cluster here i will
automatically instantiate it um but in
in the future we'll then say we'll
explicitly create a cluster my
kubernetes cluster my dashboard on hpc
cluster my desk on a big vm over there
to ask uncoiled as an option and then i
can use my existing code
um also i'll show you guys i'd better
speed up we could do this exact same
thing with gpus which is really cool uh
we can use if you have multiple gpu
cards on either your machine on a big vm
you can use das to paralyze across
to distribute excuse me across all those
those gpu cards which are really good at
parallelization um so let's let me show
this quickly um
so and i'm not a finance guy uh but i
got this from the python for finance
book which is a great one by um yves
hilfish and so we're going to do uh
european call options simulation strike
price time to maturity
and i've got you know i've got this
function
set out
and i can go ahead and run it
one time and i get back the value of
this option great now i
i this is a bad finance example but i'm
trying to keep it something clean enough
for for us
let's say that any one of these
parameters we would like to we would
like to do a simulation with a list of
these i'm just going to use a list of a
handful of these but as you can imagine
we see often it's like hey i i wanted
what's the price of this option in the
event of x y z except instead of x y z
it's 16 billion different combinations
of things i just want to keep simulating
across any world event you know if if
russia invades ukraine how does that
affect you know if the timberwolves beat
the whoever like all that sorts of stuff
and so this is my maybe quick attempt
here to uh
to model this and principally i'm not
claiming this is good das code i'm just
saying that it works
all i do is take my existing function
here and i'm going to run a little for
loop i'm going to loop over this element
this could be a dash array that i'm
going to our gas data framework to apply
something it could be a bunch of stuff
but i'm going to do that exact same desk
delayed option
and when i run this now oh gosh oh i
didn't report this no i'm embarrassed
there we go
i get back these delayed objects
and i i can visualize these individually
and see that basically each one of these
is my task
i i i mention this again not because
this is clever but because it's the
opposite this is like a real brute force
approach all i did was say okay i'm
going to iterate through this list
but i want das to blow that i want das
to run each one of these operations in
parallel if it can and then i'll run it
over a cluster later on if i need to if
it's not running as fast as i want
instead of going back to that like desk
one not to use to ask instead of profile
sample instead of optimizing compiling i
just can be lazy and do this right and
you can too
um and so now we can go ahead and run
this
and we can visualize our tasks here
and we can actually run compute and
there finally we see the tasks executed
on the right these are the tasks across
our course and i get back my result here
and i can i can total this up and you'll
see the red shows the network
serialization here as we're pulling back
some data
so uh this was my kind of like
ugly but hopefully meaningful example
for people who have existing python uh
existing python code in their domain you
can start to paralyze and distribute
this
with das
and
oh gosh uh let me
close this out now
i'll make this big again
and i'll go ahead and restart this
kernel so i don't overwhelm my local
machine
um
i
am loath to go back to slides at the
moment uh instead actually i want to
show you one more
example that has to do with uh with desk
and notebooks and that's going to be
over here
um
again no no complaints i appreciate no
no one's stopping me so i'm taking that
as a sign of encouragement um i've been
running everything so far
on my local machine
desk works really well i mentioned that
in that graphic it's like local machine
or a big server and then cluster so
let's let's pick the middle option let's
go big server
and i'm i'm inside of google cloud
google cloud platform here uh in their
jupyter notebook service is called
vertex ai i don't know why it's called
that uh but it's similar to amazon aws
sagemaker it's just cheaper and so what
i have here is actually a relatively
modest machine for
vcpus and 15 gigs of ram but
i've got a little tesla t4 gpu which is
like a nice mixture of economy and
performance so i'm calling this because
you know it's my credit card on this
account i'm calling this my big server
for the purchase of our demo and so i
can open up jupiter labs and i can now
use desk within this which is really
really nice
so uh
when i have a gpu
or sorry so just a brief intro to the to
the gpu side of the house uh there are
gpu enabled
why are there gpu libraries for doing
stuff with data frames and arrays
and thanks to the good folks at nvidia
in particular those on a team called the
rapids team actually
make sure the
the rapids docks are up so if you if you
have a gpu or if you're interested um
rapids is an open source package
that solves the nasty problem trying to
figure out versions with particular cuda
drivers the underlying driver that's
needed to work with the gpu
so very very helpful like tell you
install this if you have this you can
pick and choose it'll tell you exactly
what to use which is super super nice
and this integrates cuda excuse me and
rapids integrate nicely with desk so if
i want a data frame and i want to use my
data frame
uh with or i have a gpu and i want to do
data frame these stuff on the gpu
i can install
one of those those environments and i
can use something called qdf cuda data
frame and i can run a little data frame
operation here i'm going to read from s3
it's this new york taxi data set that is
kind of the hello world of big data even
actually although i just have one of
them um
you may be a little bit sick of it and i
go ahead and do a group by and and grab
a column and do the mean so we can see
the average tip by passenger account
which should look just like panda's code
uh
let's do the oh i don't have a simple
interface here i'm sorry you're seeing
let me at least get this out of the way
this is so exciting but oh no i can't
believe that
you know it's almost time we usually
have a 45 minute
oh talking i'm so sorry okay then um
yeah yeah uh yo local cuda cluster this
will let you use to ask and you can do
this across your your home machine um i
will go back then if i can to conclude
uh if you like this you can use to ask
across a lot of different places it's
using a lot of different industries um
you can deploy desk on a cluster in a
bunch of different ways maybe i'll just
highlight this single machine
hpc cloud dash platforms
if you have a team of people the open
source option you probably like is
called das gateway
if you don't want to mess with yourself
i work in sales account executive for a
company called coil do you provide desk
clusters of service email me and i will
give you free credits uh and if you have
dash problems you can email me too
because most of the das containers work
with us we can try to fix them uh thanks
so much i'm sorry for writing it over
um i'll stop sharing here and if you
guys have i
oh yeah it's really apologize
i totally forgot about time um maybe we
could ask god gus to take one question
from the audience
any questions
so um i i have one if there's no no no
question from from i have questions for
myself too unless you actually have a
genuine one i know but i mean like ones
that are commonly asked i'm happy to ask
a question or two if that would be
helpful but do you want to answer your
own question no
sure sure yeah uh absolutely oh wait we
did get one in the chat and see if i can
answer it yeah um
can you show how multi-column sorting of
data frame works ooh that terrifies me
um so actually so someone asked evan
asked a great question which is like
hey can you show something in pandas uh
that that should work and i i suspect
maybe evan if you've tried this with
desk and it didn't work exactly as you
expected there are some gaps here uh and
in fact i didn't even get into one of my
kind of favorite examples here for where
das can not work um but let me jump over
here i don't know if my cluster is still
running but there are a host of areas
where you're going to see differences
especially the data frame api like dash
data frame dot head will always work
dash data frame dot tail may not because
we
ask
we don't mean this is lazy it can't see
if presuming it's a huge data frame it's
simplest answer like what those data
types are what constitutes the end um it
can cause problems that was a poor
rushed explanation but in the event that
you have questions this is new and not a
lot of people know about it but there is
a discourse for desk so if you have
usage questions like why the heck isn't
this thing doing what it's supposed to
be doing come in here come to das data
frame post your question
uh at coiled a number of the desk
engineers they have okr so it's part of
their they're evaluated on how quickly
and how well they answered questions
here i'm going to think that i can share
that so go ahead and post you'll get
really good support from people who know
to ask really really well um and if
nobody answers you send me an email gus
cole.io and i can i can tap them um to
evan's question so if if assuming that
doesn't work exactly as you would expect
evan
um
and if i have time uh i'll go ahead and
ask my own question uh which was going
to be
uh d for dash deployment in the cloud or
if i want more desk examples where can i
find them
examples.dash.org this will take you
through the different interface or the
collections but also show you end-to-end
examples stuff that you can run all with
binder links which is really really nice
and then the second thing is if you had
to ask me what's your favorite way to
deploy das not using coil the thing that
i sell it would be desk gateway is what
we see most often and i'll just quickly
show you a little diagram here uh which
we you'll stand up a gateway server so
that now you can have multi-tenant
individual users come in and spin up
clusters you can put control around it
it's a really great project again free
is in free beer open source and if you
don't like that you can come check out
coiled but this is a really cool project
actually fantastic talk thank you guys i
feel energized by your um
you know um
talking uh i hope you would let us
invite you back sometime in the near
future thank you so much for having me
this was really a pleasure um i'm sorry
maybe i'm one of the few who laments
that i'm sure there's a lot we can't do
this in person um but i i certainly do i
don't live in chicago though so i
wouldn't be there otherwise in north
carolina so thank you thanks for
the remote i appreciate um
well very lucky for us okay thank you
all um
bye for now
bye for now have a good night good night